El sistema de numeración binario funciona de
la misma manera que el sistema de numeración
decimal, la única diferencia es lo que
representa a cada una de estas posiciones.
Eeste es un número binario de cuatro dígitos 1010
Cada uno de estos dígitos también puede
llamarse un bit ya que un bit representa 0 o 1.
Ahora, este número binario de 4 dígitos es igual
al número decimal 10 y vamos a ver por qué.
Esta primera posición es la posición de las
unidades igual que en el sistema decimal. Como
tenemos un 0 significa que multiplicaremos 0
por 1 que nos da el increíble valor de 0.
En la segunda posición es decir el segundo
vida de por aquí es donde las cosas se ponen
más interesantes. Esta es la posición del 2,
¡ten cuidado!, no es la posición de las decenas.
Como tenemos un 1 aquí multiplicamos 1 por 2
hasta ahora este número es igual a 2. En la
tercera posición, es decir en este tercer bit,
tenemos la posición del 4. Como tenemos un 0
multiplicamos 0 por 4 lo cual de nuevo es 0,
sigue siendo equivalente al número 2.
Finalmente en el cuarto bit de aquí
tenemos la posición del 8 y aquí tenemos un
1, entonces multiplicaremos 1 por 8 lo cual
es 8. Sumamos eso a todos los demás y tendremos
8 más 2 que es igual a 10 en el sistema decimal.
En el sistema decimal cada una de estas
posiciones representa una potencia de 10
mientras que en el sistema binario cada posición
representa una potencia de 2. El primer bit es 2
elevado a la potencia cero que es igual a 1.
El segundo bit es 2 elevado a la potencia 1,
a la primera potencia, que es igual a 2. El tercer
bit es 2 elevado a la potencia 2, 2 al cuadrado,
que es igual a 4. Y el cuarto bit es 2 elevado
a la potencia 3, 2 al cubo, que es igual a 8.
Esta es la única diferencia entre el
sistema decimal y el sistema binario
lo que representa cada una de las posiciones.
Una vez que sabemos esto tenemos que ver el dígito
que se encuentra en cada posición, multiplicamos
esos dígitos por el valor de su posición y,
después de sumar todo, obtenemos el valor final.
Bien intentemos convertir otro número binario a
decimal. Borremos todo esto y para nuestro
nuevo número binario invirtamos los bits:
0 se convierte en 1, 1 se convierte en 0, 0 se
convierte en 1, y 1 se convierte en 0, ¿a qué
crees que sea igual este número en el sistema
decimal? Te daré un momento para pensarlo...
Shala la la la la la la la la la.
Muy bien, vamos a encontrarlo juntos.
Tenemos un uno en la posición del uno así
que hasta ahora esto es 1. 1 por 1 es 1,
¡jaja!, y después tenemos un cero en la
posición del 2 así que sumaremos 0 por 2
que es cero. Tenemos un 1 en la posición del
4 así que sumaremos 1 por 4 que es 4. Bien,
hasta ahora tenemos cuatro más uno y por último
tenemos un cero en la posición del 8. Cero por 8
es cero. Entonces tenemos 0 más 4 más 0 más uno,
lo cual es igual a cinco en el sistema decimal.
Ahora intentemos convertir un
número binario más grande a decimal.
Sabemos que esto es 5. ¿Qué
pasará si agregamos 4 dígitos
más a la izquierda de estos 4 dígitos iniciales?
Empecemos encontrando qué valor representa cada
posición. Una forma de hacerlo es duplicando
el valor de la posición anterior, así que
esta posición de aquí es 16, esta posición es 32,
esta posición es 64, y esta otra posición es 128.
Otra forma de hacerlo es calculando
las respectivas potencias de 2. Esta
posición es 2 elevado a la cuarta potencia que
es 16, esta posición estos elevado a la quinta
potencia que es 32, esta es 2 elevado a la sexta
potencia que 64, y por último, esta posición
es 2 elevado a la séptima potencia que es 128.
Bien, ahora que sabemos qué valor representa cada
posición podemos sumar estos números de arriba.
Ya sabemos que todo esto es igual a 5,
ya lo hicimos, ahora a eso vamos a sumarle lo que
tenemos aquí. Tenemos un 1 en la posición del 16,
eso significa que sumaremos 16 al valor final.
Después tenemos un cero en la posición del 32,
lo cual será sólo 0. Tenemos un 1 en la posición
del 64, esto será 64. Y tenemos un cero en
la posición del 128, esto será cero.
Por lo tanto tenemos 64 más 16 más 5
eso es ochenta más cinco, que
es 85 en el sistema decimal.
Observa que utilizamos 8 bits para representar un
número que requiere solo dos dígitos en el sistema
decimal. Esto se debe a que cada bit representa
menos información: sólo un 0 o 1, en lugar de
0 a 9, pero es más fácil para el hardware de la
computadora almacenar valores binarios, es decir,
los números binarios y el sistema numérico
binario son la base de toda la computación.